mark let's talk about the interrogation
let's talk about the beginnings of it
how you begin to use it with an actor
how you came up with the idea the
interrogation process that I use with
actors is not something I quote came up
with it's something I literally
discovered during a very long process
I've been working as a director for 30
40 years something like that I lose
track of how many years and it's one of
those things that I look back over my
career and I realize what I've been
doing I didn't realize this until maybe
10 years ago what I've been doing I've
been constantly in a process of
experimentation and directing
experimentation working with actors an
experimentation that has headed the core
a very simple question there must be a
better way to do this there's got to be
another way there are a lot of great
ways of doing this now
when you think about what we're doing
which we talked about before we're all
storytellers directors writers and
actors are all storytellers and our goal
as I see it is to tell stories as
honestly truthfully openly and
authentically as possible and at the
center of these stories are characters
so we want characters to be honest
truthful and authentic characters not
that the character is always telling the
truth I don't mean that but we're
presenting the character as honestly as
we can and through the years going way
back now I'm going back to Stanislavski
which is the early 1900's
he caused a great shift in this process
of acting which you probably know about
from quote presentational acting there
was a book I had once in which I wish I
could find I think I'd lost it it was
actually a book that was written in the
I think late 1800s that for actors
showing all the positions that are
active could hold to portray or relate
an emotion to the audience and if you
look at the early films the films was
the ones before sound you can see this
you know what this meant and this looks
in other words and this book was a
wonderful book as it showed all these it
says this is how you do it this is how
you act this is how you portray this and
so that's presentational acting and what
Stanislavski was doing in the early
1900's he asked a very simple question
confound question he was struggling with
the fact that in the Moscow Art Theatre
they give a performance or he'd give a
performance or the actors he's working
with would give her performance and it
would be powerful and the next night it
wouldn't be there was no consistency
sometimes it would be I feel I think and
other times it feels really false and
fake and so he was asking how can we
stay closer to those powerful
performances that feel real or even he
is an actor when I feel like I'm really
connected with the character so he did
this very significant thing he shifted
at that time there's a seismic shift
let's take our mind off of acting and
let's look at the character and let's
talk about the character what the
character wants what the character needs
what's in the way of the character
getting what he wants how he's trying to
get what he wants let's look at what the
character is doing and stop thinking
about what I am doing as an actor or
what the other actors are doing is act
or how we think we should portray this
let's try to understand the character
that was the big shift instead boskie
shifting to the character now this led
to as you know the group theater and
Harold Clurman Bobby Lewis Stella Adler
Strasburg Sanford Meisner all the
peoples in the group theater who studied
a lot of them studying with Stanislavski
went and learned from him and this
changed the way theater was done in this
country the way acting was done this gun
became more realistic eventually became
known as method acting but it was a
focused point let's present real life
real behavior rather than presentational
behavior or acting by activating
pretending pretending to be said to
pretending to be angry can we actually
do performances where that genuine
emotion is is exhibited and felt within
the actor and that's what happened and
then Strasbourg and Strasbourg and Elia
Kazan Elia Kazan I hope you know that
he's the one that created the Actors
Studio and eventually turned it over to
Strasbourg who turned it into what he's
turned in at that active studio and then
Sanford Meisner who was also a member of
the group theatre felt he felt there's a
better way now he split off from that
group Strasbourg went ahead and formed
and reinforced the method acting the
method acting which is the actor trying
to stimulate those emotions from within
himself
based on his own life history sense
memory experiences and seeing can I
generate those genuine feelings Meisner
said that's not what the folks primary
focus should be Meisner said the focus
needs to be on the other character on
the event what is actually happening in
the moment so that so that was a split
that happened in the group theatre and
so now we have the method for technique
on this and then we have the Meisner
technique which are different but they
actually complement each other now I'm
coming through theatre at the same time
I actually studied I'm very happy to say
this with some of these people I study
with Harold Clurman Bobby Lewis Stella
Adler a lot of people from the group
theatre I did not study with Sanford
Meisner
I wish I had but I've studied a lot of
his work and there's a great documentary
out there by Sydney on the mice
otech he follows sandra miser for a
whole month through a whole class and so
I've studied that so my pursuit was
similar to this there's got to be
another way not dismissing any of this
but seeing these as stepping stones
which I've done in my voice I've studied
all this and I keep experimenting and
there was about 10 8 10 years ago
something
hit me which was rather startling to me
which was and I was actually in
Amsterdam teaching at the Binger
Institute at the time and that actors
are dealing always always their pursuit
is to try to become the character the
director is helping everybody's helping
trying to get the actor to become the
character and the actor is dealing with
certain obstacles enormous obstacles in
that path but what hit me at one point
was one of the biggest obstacles to be
act of any actor to be able to do that
was the act of themselves and ironically
the intent to become a character gets in
the way of becoming the character the
intention the hard work of becoming the
character will get in the way how can
you become a character when all you're
thinking about is becoming the character
that is not what the character is
thinking about it was really bizarre
when I started to play with this idea
when an Amsterdam I said and I didn't
really know this is one thing I
discovered it I didn't really know what
I was saying I said to the group of
directors now these are working
directors and we've made many films and
all professional directors and this
whole workshop was on working with
actors and I said to one of the
directors I tell you what did here's
what you need to do you need to stop
directing the actor because what well
this is the what the whole workshop is I
said stop it stop directing the actor
direct the character and they looked at
me and tell you the truth Kent at that
moment I wasn't quite sure what I had
said and it's one of those moments in my
teaching career one of those wonderful
moments where I say something and I have
no idea what it means but I have a
feeling it's good but really there's
something there
and so the I remember the directors say
well show me what you mean so I said
okay now I turned to the actor and I
stopped I didn't talk to the act I
talked to her character
I'm talking to her character and I'm
starting asking the character question
to know this is where the interrogation
started I said asking and what I'm
seeing is suddenly this character start
to emerge this character starting to
emerge because I'm questioning the
character I'm not saying to the actor
this is what I want you to do I'm not
questioning the character about what she
thinks about the her character I'm not
doing any of that I'm just talking to
the characters and who are you what are
you doing what are you doing why you
want to submit and starting to probe
inside the and what happened was this
character image we all set they won my
god this is amazing how the rest of the
workshop went that way when shifted
dramatically still with me not quite
sure what I had done but feeling this
I'm on to something and it was during
that workshop that the word
interrogation came up because someone
said what are you doing I said well I'm
interrogating so that's where the world
that's where it became called the
interrogation process it wasn't until
much later I kept doing this I kept
experimenting as I had my whole life
experimenting with everything that I
kept using this technique teaching this
technique even though I didn't quite
understand it and starting to
deconstruct it and spent a long time
which as I mentioned to you before and
Elsa and I have been doing this still
deconstructing is still trying to figure
out why it works and how it works and
where deeper and deeper this to
understand what this process is and what
became clear to me after a while not
immediately was that I'm talking to a
character now I'm asking a character
very simple but very profound and
questions pushing the character to
answer questions after that experiencing
and Amsterdam
I kept exploring what I had stumbled
upon and I literally mean I feel like I
stumbled upon something in many forms
and there was one time I was working on
I think it was here in Los Angeles
and I decided to ask myself ok I'm
talking to an actor I'm sorry I'm
talking to a character and I'm
questioning the character I'm
interrogating the character I'm pushing
the character and the character is
responding maybe resisting me but is not
refusing this engagement and I know that
this makes no sense at all it's totally
illogical first of all as we talked
about before the character the character
does not know that she's in a movie does
not is not in a movie so I'm not can ask
questions about movie making lines
script like but I can ask questions
about who they are what they want what
they're doing anything I want but the
question became to my mind who is she
talking to Who am I
because if she's not a character in a
movie she's not participating in a movie
but she's just herself she doesn't have
a director Who am I and then it became
clear to me I am NOT a character that
she's responded Who I am I am the voices
in her head what I call the committee
the committee is a collection of voices
that we all have each of us has all
these voices in our head that we'd have
debates with the discussions that have
opinions and attitudes and that what I'm
doing is I'm giving voice to the
committee in the character's head not
the actors at the character's head in
fact I am creating a character by
creating the characters committee and
allowing the character to respond to her
own committee and her response every
response creates the character so I'm
creating the character from deep deep
inside the character actually without
the help of the actor the actors
attitude of feelings or opinions about
the character are fine but they as many
actors have told me there's no room to
that the character is working so hard to
manage her way through this
interrogation there's no room for the
actor
imagination or creativity to come in
although I do believe unconsciously it
is working but the character is being
formed from inside the character to the
point where the character can take over
completely
you